- Hello, Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going
to solve all the major
problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn seven
ways to crush it in your niche
on social media.
And always, guys, as you're listening,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to stick
with yourself too.
Enjoy.
- [Staticky Voice] Nine, eight ...
(funky electronic music)
- So because of the success
that I've had on social media
I often get asked by people
who want to get their channels
going and started.
How do I have more success on my channels?
How do I get more impact, more influence,
help reach my goals?
What's your advice on
what I should be doing?
And so today I'm going
to share my seven ways,
seven techniques for you to crush it
in your niche on social media.
Way number one is you have
to find the right platform.
Find the best platform for you.
And it starts with combining two things.
One is what are your skills,
what are you really good at,
what do you enjoy doing, what
do you want to get better at?
So do you like being
in front of the camera,
like I do?
Would you rather do podcasts
and just do audio only?
Would you rather write, and
you can't stand the thought
of being in front of a camera?
Where do your skills line
up and the content that
you're going to share?
Are you a graphic designer,
do you want to create
beautiful images?
Are you a videographer, you
want to behind the camera,
editing great things?
What are the skills you have?
And combine it with
where are your customers?
So for me, I love Youtube
because I get to be
in front of the camera.
It's where I have the most skills.
I'd much rather make a video
than I would write a blog post.
And I go to Youtube
because it's where most
of my audience is.
My audience are entrepreneurs,
or budding entrepreneurs,
and wannabe entrepreneurs.
And a lot of you guys are on Youtube.
And you're watching.
And so that combination works
really really really well for me.
It's why I've invested so
much of my time into Youtube
as opposed to the other platforms.
And so understanding one,
what you're really good at,
where your passion lies,
what skills you have,
with two, where is your target market,
where is your audience?
And then what platform,
which social media platform,
performs the best across those two things.
And I wouldn't try to do
every single social media
platform to start.
'Cause this is what happens,
entrepreneurs try to do everything,
and then you end up doing nothing well.
And you're posting crap to
all of these different places.
So pick the one and start there.
Pick the one that has the best results,
the best potential results for you,
and go all in on that one to start with.
Number two is just start.
A lot of people just don't start.
You have an idea, one day I'm
going to start a Youtube channel.
I have this big vision
for what I want to do,
but you don't actually do anything.
And this is where your
perfectionism can be a problem.
A lot of people, they don't want to start
until it's perfect.
They need to have the perfect channel art
and to have the perfect setup,
you need the perfect gear.
You need the perfect logo,
I need the perfect name.
All this stuff has to be perfect,
and because you want it to be perfect,
you don't do anything.
You never actually take any action.
You just live in your
head of this future thing
that you want to do.
And so if you want to do it, just start.
Start, expect it to be crap, it's okay
'cause nobody is paying
attention to you yet.
You're just getting started.
You don't have a ton of
followers that you're going to
mess up with.
Just start and make it better the next day
and better the next day
and better the next day.
As soon as you get any kind of idea,
the best thing you can
do is take some kind
of immediate action towards
achieving your goal.
Whether it's social media
or any other kind of goal.
Immediate action.
You get an idea, just start.
Do something immediately,
right away, right now.
If it's a social media platform
that you're interested in,
you want to start a
Youtube channel, start it.
Go to Youtube, create
your account and record
a video today.
Expect it to be terrible,
expect it to be garbage.
That's okay, it's your first video.
Just make tomorrow's better.
Just start.
Number three is model success.
Anytime you don't know
how to do something,
the best thing you can
do is look for somebody
who's already accomplished
what you want to do
and look at the steps that they took.
And you can look at where they're at now,
but you can also look at their journey
and the path that they
took and learn from them.
So for Youtube as an example,
there's a number of
people that I look up to
that I've learned from.
I love watching Gary Vaynerchuk's channel,
I love watching Lewis Howes's channel.
There's a number of other
channels that I look up to,
I learned a ton from.
Tim Shmoyer, Derral Eves,
on how to build a proper
Youtube channel, and the right
things to do, and strategies.
And so I'd be constantly
looking for people
that I can learn from in your industry.
So if you want to be big on Youtube,
if you want to be big on
Instagram, or big on Twitter,
or big on LinkedIn,
look at the people who
are already crushing it,
understand their path, break it down.
Go back on their history
and their timeline
and try to do a research to understand
what were the things that they
did to achieve their success.
And what I love looking at most is
what was the turning point for them?
What was the breaking
point that turned them from
just someone who was doing
okay to really crushing it.
And if you look at that,
for a lot of different
people in your field,
you'll get enough of an
idea what you need to do
to be successful.
Tip number four is be a storyteller.
The reason you want to be
a storyteller is so that
people can relate to you on a human level.
When they do that, it's
not the product anymore
that it's about, but the story behind it.
And what that means is
that they're more inclined
to follow you on social media,
to purchase your products
and to promote it to their friends.
Because they identify with you.
So for example, me personally,
I am on Snapchat, I am on
Instagram, I am on Facebook.
Whenever I do posts, it's not
just a matter of me saying,
hey guys, here are the
prices for all the classes
coming up.
Hey guys, here is a brand new social.
You should come out and dance.
I let clients, customers and friends
make sure that they can
see the behind the scenes
of what I do day to day,
which helps them relate to me,
which helps them bond with me
and ultimately gives more
value than just the thing
that we offer at the school.
As a result, people are reaching
out and joining our school
when they've never even
heard of it except through
the social media, where
they watch the Snaps,
where they watch the Instagram posts
or where they're on Facebook.
Ultimately, there are a lot
of ways to reach your clients.
But altogether, you want
to make sure that again,
you're a storyteller and
you are not just promoting
the product or niche that you're in.
Tip number five is do collabs.
One of the fastest way
to grow your presence
and audience in a niche
is to do collaborations
with people who are already in your niche,
serving the same audience.
Now they may not be exact
competitors of yours,
because you have your
message, they have theirs.
But if you're targeting the same people,
and you can provide some
kind of value to them,
then it's a great opportunity
for you to be able
to build up your
influence in your network.
One of the first people
I did a collaboration
with Tim Schmoyer, he has a
channel called Video Creators.
And, again, I mentioned
I love that channel.
I used it a lot to learn
how to build up my channel.
And I was a big fan of what he did
and I reached out and we connected.
I said, hey, I'd love to
be a part of your channel.
Here are some ideas that I could present
that I think would be of interest to you
and really provide some
value to your audience.
And we picked one and
that was the first piece
of content that went up.
And it was great, because
Tim's audience is entrepreneurs
but Tim will teach people how
to build a Youtube channel.
And I'll teach people
how to be entrepreneurs.
And so, I'm not sharing
the exact same advice
that Tim is.
And so, I went on his
channel, he eventually came
on my channel.
I think I've done three or
more collabs on Tim's channel.
I just came back from
Climber Con in Palm Springs.
Met other Youtubers.
Ended up doing four or five
different collaborations
on different people's channels.
So if you're reaching
out to do collaborations,
the ideal people are the ones
that you already know of.
You've already consumed their content.
You already know what message
is going to hit for them.
You're a fan of their channel.
You engage in their channel.
Ideally, you want to be a known quantity.
You've left comments on their videos,
you've engaged with them on Twitter.
You've connected somehow in a
little bit of a back and forth
so that when you reach out and say,
hey, I'd love to do a collaboration,
here are some ideas I have,
they already know who
you are because not maybe
of the great content you've put up,
'cause maybe you're just getting started,
but because of the
interaction that you have
already made with them.
And that's easy to do,
it's just providing value
on what they're already doing.
So if they're big on Twitter,
respond to them on Twitter.
If they're big on Youtube,
make a comment on every
single video.
You should be a known quantity to them
before you reach out to
make a collaboration.
Once you do, collaborations
are one of the best
ways you will quickly grow an audience.
Tip number six is build a team.
At the start, you got to
do everything yourself.
I'm a big believer in not spending money
until you're making money.
So I do everything myself.
When I first started this Youtube channel,
I did everything.
I was in front of the camera,
I was behind the camera,
I was editing, I was researching,
I was doing the SCO, I was
do everything for my channel.
And because of that, I
was doing a video a month
to a video a week.
That was the max that I could do.
As I started earning some more money,
I said, okay, I'm getting
serious about this.
I want to start to build a team.
And the first person I hired was somebody
to do my editing.
Because I hated it, and
I was super slow at it.
And that allowed me to
go from a video a week
to a video a day.
Just hiring somebody to
do the editing for me.
I got to spend more
time doing what I love.
He was way better at
doing the editing anyway.
And my channel started to lift and grow.
Now I've got eight people who
work on my Youtube channel.
It allows me to make three videos a day.
Because of the people that
I've surrounded myself with,
I'm able to put out more content
and I'm able to spend my
time doing what I think
I'm great at and not worry
about everything else
that's associated with
building up my channel.
And so, at the start,
you start at the start.
You do everything yourself.
You can't compare yourself
to where somebody else is at
in their middle.
So you start at the start,
you do everything yourself.
But quickly start to think about
what is it that you are
great at and where you want
to spend your time at,
and as soon as you start making
some money on the channel,
on any social media channel
that you're working on,
start to think about,
okay, as soon as I
start making some money,
this is the first person
I'm going to hire.
Start thinking immediately
that you're planning
to hire people to turn
this into a business,
will allow you to focus
on what you are great at.
And tip number seven, and
probably my most important tip
is be consistent.
So many of you guys are
not consistent enough
to have success.
It's a real problem.
If you look at my channel,
why has my Youtube channel
grown so much?
I've made over 5,000 videos.
Only 4,000 of them are public.
We've got 1,000 non-public
just practice videos
that I put up on my channel.
5,000 videos.
I wasn't very good at the start.
If you go back on my channel
and look at my earlier videos,
you'll see that I wasn't very good.
I wasn't very comfortable, I was nervous,
I was stuttering, I was
trying to find my path.
It wasn't very good.
And with more practice, and as I did more,
I got better and it also
trains the audience.
People come when they
expect to get more content
and it plays well with
the Youtube algorithm
or whatever algorithm you're
posting to on social media.
You need to be consistent.
And so so many people start
and they make one video,
or they make one piece of content.
And that's it, and they fall off.
And the next week,
maybe they make one more
and they fall back down.
The next week ...
You got to put it in your calendar.
If you want to crush it
in anything that you do,
it's the topic, how are we going
to crush it on social media.
If you want to crush it
in anything that you do,
you have to spend the time.
You got to dedicate the
time to make it great.
Yes, there are shortcuts.
Yes, you can model success.
Yes, you can get there faster.
But you still have to spend the time.
It's not just going to happen.
You're not going to turn on the camera
and just be amazing and get
five million subscribers.
You got to be consistent.
And so look at your calendar
and factor in the time,
either every day or a big
chunk of time every week
to spend on your social media,
creating better content.
And I'm a firm believer
that the quantity leads
to the quality.
The quality is what's
going to get you the base,
the subscribers, the brand deals,
the attention, the impact.
It's the quality content.
But to get to the quality,
you have to produce
a ton of quantity.
Just like anything else.
To get the muscles, you have
to lift a lot of weights.
To get good at a language,
you have to practice
over and over and over again.
The quantity leads to the quality.
And so you need to be
consistent in your output.
So these are my seven tips on what to do
to crush it in your niche on social media.
I'd love to know, what did you guys think?
What was your favorite rule?
Is there an eight, nine, 10 that
you want to add to the list?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I made this video because
Brett Vaughn asked me to.
So if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
in a future seven ways video,
(book thuds)
check out the link in the description,
and cast your vote.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Vincent Montello.
Vincent, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word,
and doing the review on
your Youtube channel.
I really really really appreciate it, man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.